en este vídeo vamos a ver la idea de la
respuesta al escalón qué es una de las
ocurrencias más comunes en la
electrónica y sucede siempre que tenemos
una resistencia y una capacitancia en
serie particularmente particularmente
ocurre miles de millones de veces por
segundo adentro de cada computadora es
por eso que queremos analizar esto con
mucho detalle la respuesta al escalón
ocurre en un circuito cuando lo
alimentamos con un voltaje escalón y
esta respuesta va a estar relacionada de
manera muy cercana a la respuesta
natural de un circuito rc y si aún no
han visto el vídeo sobre la respuesta
natural los invito a que lo vean ya que
aquí vamos a ocupar ese resultado en la
respuesta natural
rc no teníamos una fuente de energía que
alimentará al circuito
teníamos un circuito rc como éste
aquí la fuente la quitamos y tenemos una
c y una
nuestro capacitor tenía un voltaje
original de 0 así que lo habíamos
cargado previamente con una carga q
calculamos la respuesta de la corriente
aquí y cuál es la respuesta del voltaje
vedete a través de este capacitor
encontramos que bb&t es igual a b 0 por
el ala menos t / rc esta es la respuesta
natural de un circuito rc lo que vamos a
hacer para la respuesta al escalón es
alimentar este circuito con un voltaje
escalón ya que si queremos que el
circuito haga algo
necesitamos estimularlo desde el
exterior lo que va a hacer el circuito
va a estar relacionado con la respuesta
natural aquí nuestro voltaje de
alimentación que llamaremos bs comienza
con un voltaje inicial de 0 y en el
tiempo cero justo aquí va a tener un
escalón pronunciado hacia otro voltaje
vez
y lo que queremos hacer es ver lo que
hace el circuito queremos encontrar esta
vedette lo que va a suceder es que antes
de que te sea igual a cero nuestro
circuito se va a encontrar en cierto
estado vamos a encontrar cuál es este y
luego vamos a perturbar al circuito de
manera que éste se va a estabilizar en
un nuevo estado al que llamaremos la
respuesta al escalón del circuito
primero vamos a resolver esto de manera
intuitiva veremos lo que ocurrió en el
pasado o hace mucho tiempo luego veremos
lo que ocurrirá dentro de mucho tiempo
después de que ocurriera este escalón y
finalmente vamos a adivinar lo que
ocurre en el ínter primero lo
resolveremos intuitivamente y después lo
resolveremos formalmente usando
matemáticas vamos a descomponer esto en
tres partes primero veremos lo que
ocurrió en el pasado
lo que hacía el circuito ayer cuando
sólo tenía de 0 de s es igual a de ser y
la corriente comenzaba a fluir desde acá
iba a llegar al capacitor iba a dejar
cierta carga aquí que se va a ir
acumulando en el capacitor y sabemos que
está relacionada con el voltaje en el
capacitor x se ve una de las cosas que
vamos a hacer mientras analizamos este
circuito es rastrear lo que le ocurre a
esta q esto es una buena forma de darnos
cuenta de lo que ocurre en el circuito
así que en el pasado de ese era igual a
b 0 y lo que ocurría es que fluía la
corriente hasta que esta vez de aquí
llegó a ser igual ha de ser así que ve
es igual a b 0 en algún momento del
pasado me llegó a ser igual a b 0 y que
le pasó ahí pues y se volvió 0 y la
por la que ocurrió esto fue porque el
voltaje a través de la resistencia que
vamos a etiquetar así le llamaremos r
eventualmente el voltaje de este lado
que era de 0 se encontró con que el
voltaje de este otro lado también llegó
a ser de 0 y esta diferencia de 0 en el
voltaje a través de la resistencia hizo
que la corriente llegara a hacer
el estado del circuito en el pasado
vamos a dibujarlo hacemos unas gráficas
de tiempo
esta será y y esta será be así que en el
pasado
b era igual a b 0 y la corriente era
igual a cero ya que grafica mos como era
el circuito en el pasado ahora vamos a
graficar cómo se da el estado del
circuito en el futuro
digamos que te va hacia el infinito
que es mucho tiempo en el futuro como
será el estado del circuito entonces el
voltaje de la fuente será de s d s es
igual a bs mayúscula noten que una b es
mayúscula y la otra minúscula el voltaje
en mayúsculas es un voltaje constante y
el voltaje en minúsculas cambia con el
tiempo ahora hacemos el mismo tipo de
análisis vamos a tener cierta corriente
que va a fluir q se va a acumular hasta
que el voltaje en el capacitor sea igual
a bs as y que tendrá una corriente
y el montaje del capacitor será igual a
b mayúscula s y sucede lo mismo el
voltaje a través de la resistencia se
volverá a cero por lo que nuevamente la
corriente será igual a cero esto
ocurrirá en el futuro vamos a graficar
lo en el futuro b tendrá el voltaje del
escalón b
y la corriente será cero en el futuro
también finalmente vamos a ver lo que
ocurre en el intermedio después de que
ocurre el pasado pero antes de que
llegue el futuro y podemos adivinar que
de cero se va a volver de ese de alguna
forma así como la corriente va a
comenzar en cero va a hacer algo y
después va a regresar a cero
vamos a tratar de mejorar nuestras
predicciones en el momento en el que
ocurre el escalón el voltaje de este
lado va a ser bs y cómo se da el voltaje
de este otro lado aquí tenemos cierta
carga almacenada en el capacitor la cual
no ha tenido tiempo de ir a ningún lado
si este es el caso entonces el voltaje
justo cuando cambia el interruptor
seguirá siendo de 0 así que aquí el
voltaje es el mismo y no va a ir a
ningún lado debido a que aquí hay una
carga física almacenada en el capacitor
aún no ha tenido tiempo de ir a ningún
lado entonces de este lado de la
resistencia tendremos b 0 justo cuando
ocurre el escalón y vean que tenemos una
diferencia de voltajes en la resistencia
por lo que tendremos una corriente vamos
a graficar la donde corresponde esta
corriente va a ser bs menos de 0 / r
esta es mi corriente y tenemos un
incremento de corriente y ahora
tendremos una carga que entra al
capacitor de manera que el voltaje en el
capacitor va a comenzar a cambiar y si
aumenta la carga va a aumentar el
voltaje así que podemos estimar que esto
se va a comportar así hay más carga que
se almacena en el capacitor lo que hace
que aumente el voltaje hasta que b sea
igual a bs hasta que el voltaje a través
de la resistencia nuevamente sea cero y
se detenga la corriente tenemos un
aumento súbito de corriente causado por
el escalón del voltaje de entrada y
luego va a disminuir poco a poco hasta
que la corriente llega de nuevo a 0 b va
de de 0 y eventualmente llegará a bs
y tendrá un escalón y luego regresará a
esta es nuestra intuición de cómo se
verá esta respuesta al escalón para un
circuito rc con alimentación más
adelante veremos todo esto en detalle y
obtendremos versiones matemáticas
precisas de cómo lucen estas curvas